i was in between agents when i moved
here from new york uh
gosh this was probably like two years
before i got the office and i remember
this assistant called
and she said hey i just want to let you
know we're passing on you because of
your age and your looks and i was like
i mean did they need to say that and i
was like is she reading a card or is she
does she have a head injury should she
not realize what she's saying to me
uh and i was like could you repeat that
because i was like please repeat that
that is like the craziest sentence i
think i've ever heard we are not hiring
you because of your age and your looks
and your looks
she said it again exactly maybe she
thought oh kate's so funny that i'm
gonna throw a zinger at her
and she's going to go god that was funny
you are giving this this woman too that
didn't have too much credit but you were
offended you were hurt i was offended
and then the minute i became famous in
the office i had her fired i'm just
kidding i know i actually don't remember
what the agency was
right but yeah but it's weird because i
was waiting tables
up and through the first season of the
office in beverly hills so wait a minute
you were waiting tables i was i mean i
was i was like co-starring guest
starring and you were in your 30s yeah
then i was and then i was 40 when i got
the office and i was still waiting
tables because i kept my job that year
um
during season one because we didn't know
if we were going to get picked up and
you know whatever but uh so i just
remember like i remember after the aspen
comedy festival i i did it and i think
it was 2003 or 2004. and then
oh no it's 2003 sorry and i think um
i just remember having a lot of meetings
after that and then waiting on the
people that um passed on me
and then hearing them with other clients
uh which was such a trip like this one
guy was given this
giving the spiel to a potential client
like you're the king
and we're just gonna we're just gonna
build you a castle i was like what the
[ __ ] like it was so weird you're hearing
it from the other side right
[Music]
when is the last time you watched an
episode of smallville tone
i mean i i don't even probably forever
what do you say we revisit well
like watch an entire episode
no i mean like watch an entire series
join tom welling and michael rosenbaum
every week as they rewind every episode
of smallville and discuss their
experiences with friends fans and
co-stars talkville the ultimate
smallville podcast
i have an agent like that who i i love
him because he really believes in me
right and he really fights for me but
some of the stuff he says is like
it's just like how do you even believe
that
like how like i could i can't even wrap
my head around like you're the next will
ferrell you are will [ __ ] pharaoh you
are funnier you're more diverse you're a
dramatic actor and i'm like going are
you on coke what are you on this guy's
brilliant he's one of my heroes i don't
i don't want to be i want to be half as
good as will ferrell i want you to look
at me and i want you to say you're half
as good and i'm like that's still really
good right right right right because if
it's if a compliment's too high then
there's a you know it's it's we're in
hollywood it's all it's helpful